G
STUBY FROM FLORIDA HE JOINS IS
RIGHT NOW.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
THAT WAS ONE OF THE MOST AMAZING
EXCHANGES I THINK I'VE EVER
SEEN.
YOU'RE IN YOUR OWN HOME AND
SHEILA JACKSON LEE TELLS YOU TO
PUT DOWN THE GUN.
WHAT IS THIS REALLY ABOUT?
>> WELL, AND SHE ALSO IN THAT
BILL THEY TELL YOU HOW TO STORE
IT.
JOE BIDEN JUST TALKED ABOUT YOU
HAVE TO HAVE A TRIGGER LOCK SO
WHEN THE PERSON IS BREAKING INTO
YOUR HOME, MAKE SURE YOU HAVE
YOUR KEY NEXT TO YOU TO GET YOUR
TRIGGER LOCK OFF YOUR GUN AND
RESPOND APPROPRIATELY.
I WAS TRYING TO HIGHLIGHT TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT THIS ISN'T
JUST A MAGAZINE BAN ON RIFLES.
THIS IS EVERY SINGLE
SEMIAUTOMATIC WEAPON THAT TAKES
MORE THAN A TEN ROUND MAGAZINE
WOULD BE BANNED, THREE OF WHICH
I JUST HAPPENED TO HAVE AND I
SHOWED TO MAKE IT VERY CLEAR
THAT A TEN ROUND MAGAZINE
DOESN'T FIT IN IT SO BY HAVING
THE MAGAZINE BAN YOU ARE
EFFECTIVELY BANNING ALL OF THESE
HANDGUNS THAT MILLIONS, HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF AMERICANS USE
EVERY SINGLE DAY TO DEFENDS
THEMSELVES, THEIR FAMILIES, TO
PROTECT THEIR HOME STAND.
>> Tucker: WHY NOT MAKE IT
REALLY SIMPLE?
WHY WOULDN'T CONGRESS REQUIRE
THAT THE LAWS PASSED RESTRICTING
AND BANNING HANDGUNS APPLY TO
THEIR OWN BODY GUARDS.
IF THEY'RE SINCERE IF HIGH
CAPACITY MAGAZINES ARE DANGEROUS
THEN WHY SHOULD SHEILA JACKSON
LEE'S BODYGUARD GET TO CARRY
THEM.
>> AND CORI BUSH IS ON THAT
COMMITTEE AND SHE SPENDS
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF HER
CAMPAIGN MONEY EVERY YEAR FOR
BODY GUARDS AND SECURITY AND I
CAN GUARANTEE THEY'RE USING THE
EXACT SAME WEAPON THAT MRS.
JONES YOU JUST HIGHLIGHTED
TALKED ABOUT BANNING AS AN
ASSAULT RIFLE OR ASSAULT WEAPON.
>> Tucker: BUT WHY SHOULDN'T THE
LAWS APPLY TO THE PEOPLE WHO
MAKE THE LAWS?
>> THEY ABSOLUTELY SHOULD.
>> Tucker: SEEMS LIKE A FAIRLY
SOLID PRINCIPLE.
>> THEY ABSOLUTELY SHOULD AND
THAT'S THE HYPOCRISY OF THE
LEFT.
OF JOE BIDEN HAS ALL THE
SECURITY, NANCY PELOSI HAS ALL
THE SECURITY, THE CAPITOL POLICE
HAVE ALL THE SECURITY YET THEY
WANT EVERY DAY AMERICANS LIKE
YOU AND ME AT OUR HOMES AND
BUSINESSES AS WE DRIVE, SOME OF
US HAVE CONCEALED CARRY PERMITS
TO NOT BE ABLE TO USE THE VERY
WEAPONS THAT WE CAN UTILIZE TO
PROTECT OUR HOMES, FAMILIES AND
LOVED ONES AND THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
>> Tucker: TIME TO SA